okay i says i'm supposed to read the
prompter and we have another surprise
it's a surprise guest i have no idea who
it is
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
oh my god
oh my god
belinda carlisle jane wiedland gina
shock charlotte kathy and kathy
valentine the go-go's everybody
oh my gosh
the last time we saw each other was at
the rock and roll hall of fame and i was
lucky enough to honor you guys
how has that been you guys feeling good
about that nod that you so what deserve
we were so excited to have you through
and i'm so happy we're all very happy
that we're celebrating your birthday
with you drew because we really do adore
you sweetheart we i and we're all really
proud of you we've watched you grow up
you know and um
you've done you you've turned out
beautifully baby you're just fabulous
yes you're fantastic oh yeah
we got the beat was released
40 years ago
give me a memory from 40 years ago if
you don't mind
mine is when we recorded it
and we went in the recording studio and
ready and raron to
get we got the beat and we played it and
then we played it again then we played
it again then we played it again and
after the tenth try
our producer richard said okay let's
take a break
and he ordered pizza
there you know
okay so it was either the magic sauce in
the pizza or the stars aligned while we
were eating but or maybe both but the
11th take was magic and we are just so
happy that
that we get to share that with you today
i love being behind the scenes that's so
exciting
what was the inspiration for that album
cover because it
the cover as well as what was inside and
all you guys was just such a life
changer it's a really iconic image and i
don't know
realize that our main goal was not to
date the the record and not like see it
20 years later and oh look at those
hairstyles and whatnot i believe it was
belinda's idea was it babe was it your
idea yeah yeah i just
yeah i don't know how it came about i
just
i thought that um
being in
towels and masks and you know about
beauty
um and not being any sort of dated
fashion um it is it's a timeless cover i
i know speaking for myself in the band
that we're so happy to be able to
celebrate this birthday with you you
know it's it's uh you feel like you're
really one of us to be perfectly honest
i know i wouldn't be the same person
if
you weren't who you were
because you did you just gave us all
permission to dream and think big and be
proud and all of us who are your fans
um
okay i'm seeing in the prompter there's
a surprise for me that there is
oh god
we love you so much and we've just
fallen in love with you all over again
that so many years later and so we want
to
invite you to be the sixth go-go
oh my god thank you to the go-go's
melinda carlile jane weaveland gina
shock charlotte caffey and kathy
valentine and please
check out the
entire inductee ceremony of the rock and
roll of hall of fame it is a true love
letter from a true blue fan to the
greatest woman on earth
[Music]
you